good morning believe nation today's
message is life is unpredictable over to
you Sally Ride awake TV go I hadn't
really planned my career around being an
astronaut I had planned to go into plan
to go into physics and to do research in
physics get a job at a university do a
little bit of research in a little bit
of teaching the application procedure I
was about to finish up my PhD and it was
time to time to go look for a job and it
was exactly at that time that NASA asked
for for applications and I heard about
it through the Center for Research on
women at Stanford NASA had had sent out
word to women's centers and minority
centers that they they were encouraging
women and minority applications so it
was really it was really through them
that I that I heard about it I love this
message because I think too many
entrepreneurs too many people are
attached to the how something will
happen instead of just the why the most
important thing is the why why are you
doing this what is the big outcome that
you want to accomplish right what is
your purpose stay focused on that and
not the how it's going to happen because
life is unpredictable because no matter
how much you plan no matter how much you
focus no matter how much you think
something is going to work out once you
actually get out to market and try your
ideas out they are likely going to fail
and what you're going to have to do is
listen to the market listen to what
people are telling you talk to your
customers and adjust make tweaks make
changes it'll take you down a different
path so it's holding on to the big
picture holding on to why this is
important hold it on to that big goal
that you're chasing after but not being
too attached to the how you're going to
go out and accomplish it I look back to
my first software company and I spent an
entire summer working on the perfect
business plan it was the perfect perfect
perfect business plan and once we
actually launched at the end of the
summer we realize that everything not
everything
a lot of the things in my business plan
were wrong a lot of my assumptions were
wrong the things that I thought were
really great ideas turned out not to be
really great ideas and that could have
cost us a lot of opportunities it costs
us a major deal where one of our
competitors got bought out and that
could have been us for a much larger
deal than what I got bought out for
because I didn't focus enough right I
focus too much on the planning the
researching the writing and not enough
on actually getting out there and
testing my assumptions I was too focused
on the how something was going to work
instead of the why getting it out there
getting feedback and testing I look at
my youtube channel now my big goal is to
help a billion entrepreneurs my next
goal my next challenge is to get to a
million entrepreneurs the rate that I'm
growing now right I'm getting 15 to
20,000 subscribers a month in a youtube
channel at that rate it's going to take
me five years to get to a million
subscribers on my channel and so that's
my big goal that's what I want to
accomplish the how has to change right
the quality of the videos that I do have
to change the content of the videos that
I do has to change I need to change and
get better if I keep doing what I'm
doing now I'm going to get the results
that I'm getting now or if I want to get
better results more quickly more
effectively more efficiently that I'm
going to have to change so I'm not
trying to be too attached to the how I
get there but I'm staying attached to
the why and the big goal so the question
the day today is are you more attached
to the y or the how I'm really curious
to find out leave your comments below
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press 0
expreso keep me going